if life began on mars it probably began
around the same time that it began on
earth so three and a half four billion
years ago but on earth
so kind of paradoxically it's much
harder to look back in time because
earth's active it's got weather it's got
you know volcanoes plate tectonics all
this stuff so the surface is constantly
being renewed and so it's very very hard
to get samples from earth
of earth as it was three and a half to
four billion years ago whereas on mars
it stopped being geologically active
about three and a half billion years ago
so it's been in deep freeze and so these
river deltas that perseverance is roving
across now
are pristine river deltas from three and
a half billion years ago they're time
capsules so it might be easier to
understand the origin of life if it
began on mars it might be much easier to
do so than it is on our own planet
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
we're getting into a realm today that is
truly one of my favorite realms to talk
about i'm the most fascinated by
probably that in psychology but in fact
we have we kind of entered into a little
bit of those realms because within the
realm of physics we have brian cox on
the show today who's a british rock star
physicist theory of anything started
with an idea we talked about black holes
consciousness
space and time fractals like so many
areas of physics and science in the
universe that um i just i just love it
and as we learn and understand more and
more about our universe we know our role
in it and know how to live our lives and
so that's why i love it so much um but
of course we talked about aliens
extraterrestrials we talked about his
the question that he wants answered in
his lifetime um which is at the end and
yeah i think you're just gonna love it
this is such a such a cool conversation
brian is touring the u.s and canada he
has i think 50 stops on his tour i was
disappointed to hear he wasn't in
phoenix yet but he's he's coming to you
so if you're interested and you're in
the states or in canada you can find
tickets to brian shows at brian cox live
dot co dot uk for any of those spots
that you want to see them in the
meantime enjoy this episode
if you like this
show if you like the kind of things that
i talk about
i would just be so honored if you would
follow if you would subscribe like it
send it to your friends and then leave
comments and the things that you guys
grab on to and really love and i see the
views then we'll just keep doing more of
them so enjoy the episode
hi what time are you in england right
now
uh yeah just about to fly to uh new york
tomorrow and the first show is
washington dc on friday that's so
exciting where do you live in england
london oh nice i lived in um i lived in
milton keynes when i was a teenager
racing oh yeah i was gonna ask why but
presumably because your your family were
there no oh no my family didn't go i was
i left when i was 16 and um they did not
come with so i lived there from 16 to 19
pretty much on my own um racing cars so
did you ever get into racing being in
england like did that ever trip your
trigger
i've never um the only
car i've driven really fast officially
was on top gear you know the oh yeah
yeah that's a very popular show and i i
went faster than bear grylls
no you didn't oh my god bear is such a
nice guy i did his show running wild
he's a really he's a really cool guy as
well he's great but he's slower than me
in a car
i'm gonna have to give him some crap
about that i'm definitely gonna text him
but like brian cox said he went faster
in a race car than you i'm trying to
guess buddy why don't you have the
bravery where's it at
because he sure does he had me jumping
out of helicopters and rappelling across
canyons and all kinds of frightening
stuff but did they have you on the show
top gear just as a guest to experience
cars or were you like breaking down the
physics of cars
no it was just a it's a thing uh it used
to be called star in a reasonably priced
car but it was a it was when they were
doing it with rally cars it was a bit of
a rallying in a mini which was quite
cool and so that's that's what i did so
i was specifically there to race bear
that's awesome well then let's like step
aside from racing because that's not at
all what i want to talk about today
your realm of expertise is so
fascinating to me the amount of time
that i walk around in the day and just
wonder what's real and what's happening
and then thinking back to when i was a
kid and looking up to the sky and goes
thinking to myself it goes on for
infinity but what is that the end of
infinite no it doesn't i can't oh my
brain
is that what you did when you were a kid
did you like did you look up at the sky
and just go i need to know
yeah i mean that that's how i got into
science it was astronomy just like you
just looking up at the night sky
something captured my imagination
and fortunately for me i made the
connection i thought well
actually learning about these points of
light and what they are is science and
so i started paying attention at school
to science because i wanted to know
about astronomy and also science fiction
actually i grew up
you know star wars was the huge thing
when i was nine ten years old um and and
so i connected all that as well and
thought it's all the same thing
and
i want to know more about it that's the
wonderful thing about astronomy as you
say is the more you learn about those
points of light in the sky the more
wonderful they become and in the morning
at the moment the planets are up kind of
early morning then jupiter for example
you know if you look at that
just through a pair of binoculars or a
small telescope you see the moons
and then you realize that one of those
moons europa
has an ocean below its surface which has
got more water than all the oceans of
the earth combined was the size of
europa similar to earth it's smaller
it's kind of almost a small planet sized
so it's smaller than the earth but it's
just water beneath the surface i was at
jpl a few weeks ago actually where they
build the space probes and um they're
building a thing called europa clipper
now which is going to go to that moon
and one of the reasons is because it's
one of our prime candidates for life
so then you know the point of light that
you're looking at might have life on it
or in it in the ocean and off you go
did that also
make you wonder when you looked out to
the sky whether or not there were other
entities out there too
well yeah and um
you know microbes might be really common
so also as we speak there's a robot
called perseverance on mars which is now
in a river delta which just arrived an
ancient river delta and it's it's taking
samples below the surface because three
and a half billion years ago that
surface was underwater and so we want to
know whether there are signs of life and
the most amazing thing about that
mission
is that perseverance the rover is the
first bit so it's packaging up samples
and it's going to leave them on the
surface of mars
and then
the next thing that another mission is
going to go and land another lander on
mars which is going to go and collect
the samples put them in a rocket
and the rocket is going to be believe it
or not catapulted up off the surface and
then they're going to light the rocket
and it's going to fly into orbit around
mars and then they're going to send
another mission which is going to go and
find this thing which has got the
samples in it which is only about the
size of a baseball and then it's going
to find it in orbit around miles get it
and then bring it back to earth and
ultimately it's going to crash land in
utah in the desert and they're going to
go and find that and bring it back to
the laboratory to look for signs of life
on mars it's the most incredible it's
called mars sample return and the more
you talk about it the more crazy
right that does sound like quite the
choreographed
um
mission um because there's so many
missions now
i've heard you talking about this before
and thinking that maybe there's
going to be information in that in those
samples in those core samples to
how life began and it might help us
understand how our life began is that
accurate yeah the the interesting thing
about mars is that if life began on mars
it probably began around the same time
that it began on earth so three and a
half four billion years ago but on earth
so kind of paradoxically it's much
harder to look back in time because
earth's active it's got weather it's got
you know volcanoes plate tectonics all
this stuff so the surface is constantly
being renewed and so it's very very hard
to get samples from earth
of earth as it was three and a half to
four billion years ago it's almost
impossible
whereas on mars it stopped being
geologically active about three and a
half billion years ago so it's been in
deep freeze and so these river deltas
that perseverance is roving across now
are pristine river deltas from
three and a half billion years ago
they're time capsules so it might be
easier to understand the origin of life
if it began on mars it might be much
easier to do so than it is on our own
planet
how far down are those
the water now is probably is way deeper
but um these were this was surpass water
three and a half billion years ago yeah
so the idea is that if there were
microbes in that river delta
then their remains are the traces
they've left
will be just below the surface and
that's why we're taking these samples to
bring back to earth
so okay so if we can look back to that
time and say maybe this is an indication
of how life started would it be
far-fetched to think that
if we just look to how we're doing it
right now
to find life that that's just how life
started then too
so like extraterrestrials or another
somebody you're finding another planet
to him to live on could it just be
someone from another planet coming to
figure out like oh look here we can this
is how it started somebody visited and
said this looks like a nice home it's
one of the one of the big questions we
have about the origin of life is of
course how often did it happen
um sold the system like ours it
obviously happened here
or did it uh because we know that
sat material is transferred between the
planets so we have martian meteorites on
the earth we have bits of the earth on
mars so that we've not found them but
because bits of mars land on earth we
assume
the bits of earth land on mars and so
it's not completely impossible
that life began once
on earth all mars
and got transferred
and so we the first thing we want to
know if we find signs of life on mars is
is it the same
so does it look you know does it have
dna is it in some sense the same as the
life on earth or is it different so was
there a different genesis
how many different ways are there of
being alive we don't know because we
have only one example which is earth so
these are profound questions and then to
go on to your next question then then
you start saying well but what what
about what's the chance that given
microbes the origin of life little cells
or something like that
what are the chances of those cells
ultimately getting together into things
like you and me
which are these hugely complex things
the most complex things we know of
anywhere in the universe the things that
can have a conversation
and think and
feel and bring meaning to the universe
in a very real sense
and all we know again is that it took
about over three billion years from the
origin of life
on earth to get anything more complex
than a single cell
it's about three billion years it's a
quarter of the age of the universe
and so
what i talk about in the live show
actually is if i was to guess and we
could we don't know but if i was to
guess how many civilizations there are
in a galaxy like the milky way with 400
billion suns and countless trillions of
planets i'd guess there might be a
handful maybe even one
which is us
i think the chances of civilizations
appearing on planets it's a big ask when
you think about it isn't it i mean to
think you know it's one thing to have
some chemicals getting together and
turning into a cell and it's a living
thing and it's a huge deal there it's a
big thing in itself
but then the idea that those cells
decide to collaborate together and build
spaceships
is a whole other
it's all of the questions right and
create these complex missions to get
things off mars
so then would it be accurate to say that
if you thought that there could be a
handful or even one
civilization in a galaxy that there
would be one to a handful in every
galaxy the milky way is not
that
atypical that we know of um
our estimate by the way for the number
of galaxies in the piece of the universe
we can see which is called the
observable universe is two trillion
it's a lot of neighbors that are not
yeah
so so yeah i think the milky way is
fairly typical we don't really see
anything that's massively unusual so i
think
i'm sure
as sure as i can be that there are
civilizations out there somewhere in the
universe but the question really if we
want to ever meet them or we really want
to you know
see extraterrestrial life the question
is how many are in our neighborhoods
and i'm being loose with the word
neighborhood because the milky way
galaxy is 150 000 light years across or
something like that with four
400 billion suns so it's big but let's
say that's our neighborhood imagine if
we're the only one in there um that's a
it's it's quite a
it's there's quite a responsibility we
have
i would say if that's the case i i was
asked to give the um
to give the intro um the the cop 26
climate summit um so it was quite an
honor actually they said to me what
would you say to the world leaders um if
you've got one message to them about the
the progress we need to make a climate
what would it be
and i said this i said that as far as i
know if you it's a possibility at least
so let's say it's our operating premise
that we are the only civilization in the
milky way galaxy at the moment
and that means that this planet this
little speck of dust notwithstanding its
physical insignificance is almost
indescribably valuable
because it could be the only place where
atoms have got together to think
and feel and in a very deep sense bring
meaning to the universe because i
would argue that you need things as
complex as human brains you need
thoughts
to have meaning
and so if you collectively were leaders
through inaction or deliberate action
remove us from this world
then you may be responsible for
eliminating meaning in a galaxy of 400
billion stars potentially forever
that's the responsibility that you have
and that's an example
of why i think that science is so
valuable it's not because it has the
answers to everything we don't have the
answers to everything science science is
fundamentally a humble pursuit it's
based on the idea that we don't know
everything therefore we try to find out
and do research
but it does give us perspective
my great hero carl sagan said that
astronomy is a humbling end character
building experience so it's humbling
because it tells us that we're tiny
suspected dust
but it's character building because it
says that we might also be extremely
valuable and we might underestimate our
cosmic significance
and so we have a tremendous
responsibility i think it's a good
working assumption and i don't think
that you know the more
the more world leaders and our
politicians the more perspective they
have and the more the more they
understand
the potential tragedy of damage in this
world i think that i really do think the
better they behave they just need to do
a bit of astronomy
i'd launch them into space but you know
people talk about commercial space maybe
we'll talk about it but one of the great
benefits for me would be to launch every
world leader into space before they
start so they can look at the earth from
space and get a sense of its beauty and
fragility and ultimately i think its
significance
and then um
and then you know we can choose maybe we
can vote which ones to bring back but
probably speaking i'd bring most of them
back again
and just say there you go now you've
seen what you are responsible for
yeah i think that's
an absolutely fantastic idea um
why is that like what is taking so long
is it do is it a complicated obviously
it's complicated but
you know from things i've heard it's
like timeline wise presumably we coulda
shoulda would have been
off planet by now is there anything that
holds that back and and i think that as
you just said talking about world
leaders and
everybody understanding what is at on
the line looking at our planet
like why are we fighting each other i
feel like there's all kinds of memes and
funny things about aliens looking down
at earth going like they're still
fighting each other down there like if
we got off planet and if world leaders
could see it from that distance maybe
they would say like
wow we're all for one instead of
fighting within it's kind of like
it's like viruses within a planet just
sort of like fighting each other yeah it
sounds honest you know it it when you
say it
and i say exactly what you just said and
it almost sounds naive in a way people
say are you being so naive but actually
if you look at the astronauts and i've
been so lucky to meet a few astronauts
and um they they all say that many of
them you know the apollo astronauts were
test pilots they're military people and
so they weren't particularly disposed to
these kind of contemplative thoughts
when they left the earth but all of them
say that they all say that there's one i
can't remember it's one of the apollo
astronauts he's he was asked what do you
think when you were you went around the
moon and saw earthrise and he said why
the hell can't we get along it vividly
sort of
comes into view when you see the earth
for what it is which is tremendously
valuable and yet fragile place and so i
think it would make a difference and and
and the the answer to your question is
we can do it now so
the real leap forward has been um
really i think the private sector now is
spacex and blue origin developing um
reusable rockets which makes it really
cheap
you know in the scheme of things i
totally i'll name drop now and
but i i spoke to uh jeff bezos i i i
it was great fun actually talking to him
and he pointed out that imagine
that you um you know transatlantic
fights i'm gonna fly to new york um
tomorrow from london
imagine that you got on the plane in
london flew to new york everyone got off
the plane and then you destroyed the
plane
right imagine how much the ticket would
be but that's what we've done
all our space exploration up until very
recently was single-use rockets and now
we don't do that anymore um then i i
think that it space is going to become
more accessible to everybody
and um hopefully therefore it should be
a responsibility shouldn't it i think
you know the next president
of the united states
he could be flown or she could be flown
into space
for a you know a fraction what is way
less than a million dollars
right you could fly them up let them
look at the earth fire them back again i
think that would be a great investment i
definitely agree
how come we haven't been to the moon in
like 50 years and how come i've seen
videos that says we lost the technology
to go to the moon
what is the truth about all that we
sort of initially lost it after the
it's 1970s it's very very difficult and
expensive to build a sat m5 in those
days
in the 60s
i'd say it was right on the edge of our
capabilities it's astonishing that we
managed to do it well they say now that
your telephone has more capabilities
than what they had in totality to fly
back
way more so it was it was almost too
hard um and i remember i got to speak to
charlie duke who um
walked on the moon apollo 16
and he said that his dad
remembered the wright brothers flight
right so his dad
remembered the wright brothers and then
saw his son walk on the moon so that's
just almost impossible to believe it was
done the other thing charlie duke said
is that he said when you've got like um
uh 700 000 engineers and unlimited
budget you can do a lot right
and so that's how they did it but then
of course at the time it was very
difficult very dangerous and very
expensive and it was one of the great
human achievements that we managed to do
it
now
it's um it's a lot less dangerous a lot
cheaper
and we have the technology and the
computing power as you say to do it
rather much more easily so that's why
we're going back now because it's not
you don't need 700 000 engineers and
unlimited budget um you now can do it
you know spacex is pretty close
to being able to do that
in the process delta flight now it's
just a delta flight you know where do
you want to go oh let's go to the moon
well it won't be long you know i don't
think it would be long until
people you know initially people with
quite a lot of money but then um that
the price will come down that peop no
ordinary people
if they really wanted you know you
sometimes go on a vacation and you say
right this i'm going to save up for 10
years and for my retirement or whatever
i'm going to go on this amazing vacation
i think people are going to be able to
hop up on the sub-orbital flights and
see the earth from space at that kind of
level within about 10 years i would
guess
so now you're saying sub-orbital that's
not the moon though that is within our
within orbit earth's orbit but not all
the way to the moon
yeah yeah the little hops that blue
origin do now and virgin galactic have
been doing you know those things and
then spacex obviously against you all
but it's much more difficult going to
the moon is still difficult
but it's nowhere near as difficult as it
was when we had you know as you said
this thing that was like not one of uh
one of the phones we have now but like a
nokia you know one of the old things
right oh i had one
it's like that right i mean it's that
computing power at best
yeah that's crazy what about um
[Music]
what do you say what what what do you
think about her what's your what is your
counter to the
conspiracy that we haven't been to the
moon and the vanish van ellen radiation
belt and all the things like
what is what is what does someone like
you say to that
total [ __ ]
just it's just nonsense but it it's you
know it's nonsense
at the same level there's lots of
nonsense in the world there's flat
people and all sorts of stuff
and so ultimately it is interesting why
there's a serious side to it it's not so
serious i suppose if people
don't believe that you know they went to
the moon or whatever it is i think the
earth is flat the problem is that what
you're seeing there is
um a distrust of
science and a distrust actually of our
political system i mean the idea
the idea
the idea that
for 50 years or more
the political system can hide
one of the this great expenditure and
hundreds of thousands of people's
experience and hide it from everybody i
mean that's nonsense in itself if you
think about it i mean they can't hide
you know you go back in you go back to
the scandals that affected past
presidents and things like that i mean
they can't you know
you can't hide anything right i mean in
our country now we've got a prime
minister who couldn't hide the fact that
he had a passage during kobe lockdown so
how the how these people are competent
enough to cover up the expenditure of
hundreds of billions of dollars over 10
years and keep hundreds of thousands of
people quiet when they can't even keep a
drinks party quiet is beyonce
the really important point though is if
it goes back to
why is it important for people to have a
basic kind of understanding of science
um it's not because you need to know the
things you know how far the moon is away
how many galaxies there are in the
observable universe it doesn't matter
whether people know that
but science is the way that we acquire
reliable knowledge about nature so it's
the the way we answer questions which
are good questions such as if we carry
on
um burning fossil fuels then will there
be an impact on the climate right that's
just a completely sensible question to
ask sure and the way that we answer
those questions and we found out that
there will be an impact and there is
being an impact is by doing science
that's important so when you so the
conspiracy theory can appear harmless
but then you get conspiracy theories
about pandemic response so climate
change and so on
those are important
problems because we live in democracies
and so if you have enough people who
really don't understand
how we acquire reliable knowledge how to
how to weigh
um
or how to seek out trusted voices in
society know what they're talking about
and then make decisions based on that
knowledge then then we have a real
problem in our democracies we're liable
to do really silly things
um so it becomes serious
um when it becomes about you know
existential threats that we face rather
than just some people thinking that
you can't fly through a van allen belts
which is
i mean i should say that you can go the
thing is you can read the um the
research that was done it's a good
question it's like it will will
launching a human being through
into
so beyond the protective cocoon of our
magnetic field and out into space will
they be able to survive the radiation
dose and it is dangerous
and astronauts do get higher than
average radiation doses and they have to
be careful and you can't launch them
when the sun's very active and actually
you have to launch them carefully so you
can avoid the worst of the radiation
that's in things like the banana belts
but you can actually read all the
research that was done
so so you can see how it was done
and and then you know the question
becomes well why don't you
why
why don't you just read
really do a bit of reading because you
know they're fun concepts and people you
know i mean
people kind of have read reaffirming
things right it takes a disciplined open
mind to be able to say okay if this is
this we have this perspective now let me
look at the opposite perspective and
evaluate all of the pers all of it so i
can make my own decision or make an
educated decision and i think probably
for
scientists and
physicists and cosmologists and everyone
in the science field that is figuring
out
new theories of things and equations is
that you guys live in that space of
being
proving things right and wrong right
everything that comes out gets highly
scrutinized and that's just part of the
process you know it's one of the most
important things um if
when you when we do science at school
right so people go to school and do
science experiments and things what are
they really learning they're not really
learning about how a pendulum swings or
whatever it is what they're really
learning about is that process of
acquiring knowledge and richard
feynman's one of my great heroes nobel
prize winning physicist
and he wrote a brilliant essay which you
can get online
you just type it in richard feynman it's
called the value of science
and and he wrote it in the mid 1950s it
was a speech he gave actually
and then he was saying what's the most
valuable thing that science gives us and
it's not you know the knowledge or even
mobile phones or
weather forecasting or
health care you know all those things
really important things but ultimately
what it is
is
humility it's it's that he called
science he defined it as a satisfactory
philosophy of ignorance which is a
beautiful definition
and it's the idea that that he said we
it's the idea that we approach doubt
and uncertainty uh not with fear
right we don't we don't approach doubt
with fear we approach it with excitement
and wonder that not knowing
admitting that you don't know is the
first step on the road to wisdom
and um feynman by the way wrote that and
he was very concerned about this
propensity that we have as human beings
to think that we know everything we get
it all the time you turn on the tv
and you go to a political chat show or
whatever it is and you get people who
think they know right they give every
impression of thinking they know how to
run a society
running a society is difficult as
feynman said in this essay that what a
democracy is
is the acceptance that we don't know how
to do it so you change it every four
years
you've got to understand that you've got
to accept the fact that you don't know
everything in order to in in order to be
a democrat
and if you you're not a democrat you're
not you don't you're not someone who
celebrates democracy i don't mean
democrat politically right i mean just
someone who supports democracy you're
not that if you think that you know how
to do everything and you're so sure
and the way we've acquired all this
knowledge that i you know i'm going to
talk about in my my shows about the size
of the universe the age of the universe
how do we measure these things how do we
know this stuff how do we build
spacecraft that go to different planets
we did it because there are some people
who accept the fact that they know they
don't know everything and so they're
very careful and they try to find out
and that's the important thing about
science and science education it's
teaching people to be humble and be
comfortable with uncertainty and then
you can move on and you can acquire
reliable knowledge about the world
is there something that
has been proven to be different than
your original opinion in your life
that's really big
all the time i mean
you know i mean the name of the game i
forget but is there something that is
central and
something that was
felt very true to you that you had to
change your mind about based on
information
actually well recently i mean um i'll
give you a physical physics example in
in a minute but um in in just the way
that i
look at society
so um so in the uk um
we had we had this big boat right and we
we left the european union all right and
and it's like i i think that's a
disaster i think it was a
bad choice
and for a while i thought he was such a
bad choice that i thought oh we've gotta
we can't do this right it's it's just
it's a it's just a terrible mistake but
then i i came to understand
what
what i've just said i mean i've always
the thing about democracy right i've
always known that i've read feynman for
years
but i thought you know actually
the fact that
decisions in your country swing against
you
so the fact that sometimes there are
people doing things that you think are
just completely
you know the wrong thing to do and you
don't agree with the government at all
you don't agree with what's happened and
then sometimes you agree and and things
go your way
the fact that that pendulum swings
is the sign that we live in a free
society like the moment
that
your government even if they're doing
everything you want if they're doing
everything you want and that pendulum is
not moving against you
then you should be really worried
because you should think well
this means that we no longer live in a
society where things are being debated
and where different opinions and
different points of view have been
celebrated and allowed
to flourish
because the majority go one way and the
majority go the other right the moment
that stops and the moment you agree with
everything is the moment you should get
very worried because you're living in a
dictatorship then you're not living in
free society anymore so so i realized by
in thinking about
a case where i really fundamentally
disagreed with the decision that people
made
i realized that actually i should
celebrate that
unfortunate as i think it is and as
disastrous as i think it is because it
tells me that i live in a free society
and the pendulum will swing back if we
make the arguments
so that so that's a
political version the the science one
i'll give you
is just it's an interesting
story the thing i'm researching at the
moment and a big part of my live show is
actually i'll be talking about black
holes and that's because black holes are
the most baffling and interesting things
and i could talk about them forever um
but one of the questions that was asked
initially by stephen hawking actually my
work he did back in the 70s was what
happens to stuff that falls in
does the the information if you throw a
book into a black hole
is the information gone from the
universe forever
and he discovered that black holes and
this really was uh what stephen hawking
is most famous for in physics he
discovered that black holes evaporate
away over time it's called hawking
radiation and so one day they're gone
so the question is is the information
gone
and for many years many years even
thought that the information was
destroyed in black holes
and then he changed his mind
and now the current view is that no the
information comes out and we're pretty
sure now almost completely sure the
information survives that process of
going into a black hole gets radiated
out into the universe and in some sense
it's never lost
um but there's there's you know one of
the great physicists of the 20th century
in 21st century stephen hawking changing
his mind because he got a deeper
understanding and more work was done and
that's what science is all about yeah
thank you those are great stories and
especially from someone brilliant like
yourself and explaining how you change
your mind and someone like stephen
hawking
um okay well then let's talk about black
holes
because i find it fascinating as well
maybe we'll back up and start with
energy just the
just the universal understanding and
maybe this is i think this is accurate
correct me if i'm wrong um that energy
can't be destroyed it's only transformed
so
everything is energy
right so even if a book went in there
it's some form of energy is this correct
yeah with that in mind then transformed
could it what could it become like what
could the things that fall into the
black hole become presumably it doesn't
always have to come out as a book right
if we're just using that exactly well no
so so the thing if you think about
something like a book
um and then if we wind back um how does
physics work as we understand it at the
fundamental level it says that if you
know everything about something let's
say a book
and then let's say we burn the book so
we set it on fire
then physics says that if we could
collect everything all the gas and all
the ashes and everything and measure
everything that came off from that fire
perfectly which is very hard to do but
if we could do it
then we could run back time and
reconstruct the book okay um so given
that we know everything about something
or with a great deal of precision at
some moment we can predict what it's
going to do in the future and what it
was doing in the past that's called
determinism
that's central to science it's how we
how we look at the universe today and
try and we model it and run it back in
time and forwards in time and we see the
big bang and we can measure the time
back and all those things
so
the question with black holes is
is that still true
so it is if we could collect everything
that comes off the black hole when it's
evaporated away through this process
called hawking radiation and it's just
particles nothing left the black hole's
gone
could some omnipotent being right in the
far future with a huge quantum computer
feed everything in and then reconstruct
everything that fell in
and the laws of nature
as we understand them at the basic level
say yes
but the laws of nature also said
as we understood them at the basic level
with the black hole
initially they said no
so we had a clash a fundamental clash
um between our with our laws of nature
contradicting themselves right
essentially that's the that was the
wonderful thing about black holes
and it turns out that now
it seems that no the the ultimately as
the black hole evaporates away the
information that fell in
uh gets imprinted into the radiation
that comes off the black hole which is a
really tremendously bizarre thing to
happen
and it's really what it's done is it
challenged us
to reassess our understanding of space
and time
and and now
the
the the the consensus view i think from
the black hole research
is that space and time are not
fundamental things
that they emerge from something deeper
einstein had this wonderful phrase
something deeply hidden he said when you
look at nature in detail you can catch a
glimpse of something deeply hidden which
is the deep structure of nature and it
seems that there is such a structure of
space and time
and what that deep structure which is
what we call quantum theory preserves
information
so the patterns the patterns evolve and
change over time but the patterns are
always there and you can always if you
could collect them and you were smart
enough you could run it back and see the
patterns in the past
so one of the most fascinating things
within science to me is fractals
like i just think fractals is
fascinating i constantly look at the way
things are and
just wonder what level like what what
part of the fractal loop we're in
is it is our universe completely is it
fractal in nature
i i think at the deep level it isn't so
fractal there's a great thing if you go
online you can look at the mandelbrot
set which is this this um mathematical
structure
ultimately and and you can you can zone
in
when i was little actually so i'm being
really geeky now i wrote a computer
program to draw one it's a really simple
thing
and in this really simple bit of
mathematics is this infinitely complex
structure and as you zoom in and then
and then you see the structure again and
the structure again and structure again
so i really recommend you go online and
look at mandelbrot set and spend an
afternoon or an evening zooming in and
exploring this bizarre land that's
mathematical
um so you can go infinitely deep
basically and carry on and you just see
pattern after pattern after pattern
repeating itself
um
but the universe what black holes have
told us is that the universe isn't like
that there's a really
weird strange
result from black hole physics
and it's that so let's say i say to you
how much information
in bits right so literally in bits of
information like the memory in your
phone how much can i put in some given
region of space
so you could look at the region of space
in front of you now just look in front
of your nose look at a little cubic
centimeter or something of space
whatever it is and say how much
information could i put in there
and the answer is
that the maximum amount of information
you can fit is you keep putting bits in
and ultimately the thing collapses into
a black hole right
so there's kind of a limit before you
make a black hole and the whole thing
collapses
and the amount of information in any
given region of space
seems to be proportional
or actually equal in some
sense to its surface area and not its
volume
so that's like saying if i was to ask
you how many books can you put in a
library how much information can you fit
in the library you'd say well it's got
to do with how many books i can fit in
it's to do with the volume of the room
how many books can i get in the room
that's it or how many hard disks or
whatever it is
but it turns out at a fundamental level
nature seems to say no
it's only about the surface
it's not about the inside at all
and so this is leading us to think that
we vastly overestimated the amount of
information you can store in any given
region of space
um and this leads to something called
the holographic principle that we could
talk about which is um
i love it i read the holographic
universe
so
a hologram is uh the basic level it's
it's a piece of film right so a flat
thing uh like a sheet of paper
two-dimensional thing with all the
information on it necessary to make a
three-dimensional image of a thing
and it seems that a very deep level the
universe is like that
and people are even it came from black
hole research but people are even now
although it's not fully understood by
any means
beginning to say well okay so that means
that
there's an equivalent description of us
so me and you and everyone that's
listening and watching there's an
equivalent description which is some in
some sense and physicists always use
that phrase by the way when they're
waving their hands around right in some
sense right so it means we don't fully
get that right we don't fully understand
it but in some sense
the the the information our thoughts and
everything that we experience is is
equally well represented on a surface
surrounding us
so it's almost it is it's a and in that
sense you could say that we're holograms
and that's called a holographic
principle and that's really bizarre but
it's coming from research in black holes
what part of the black hole is that all
the information's on the outside
well so the problem with a black hole is
that from the outside
the thing behaves in a certain way and
that's how we view it right so we're out
we see one there's a there's a galaxy
called m87 for example about 55 million
light years away and we have a
photograph of the black hole
in that galaxy and it's a huge black
hole six billion times the mass of the
sun supermassive black hole so we know
these things exist we've got a picture
of one in that galaxy
and so from the outside um they're weird
right so if i was to if if i said to you
you go into the journey into the black
hole
and i watched you go in so i sat from
afar and watched you fall in
i would i would never see you cross into
the black hole
you would you would freeze on what's
called the event horizon
and it's actually the from some
perspectives yeah i could i could
imagine that you actually were
completely incinerated on the event
horizon and all your ashes came out into
space and i could collect them and i
could reconstruct you right if i was
clever
so i could do that but yeah
but from your perspective you would fall
in across the horizon inside of the
black hole you go into the interior of
the black hole you could float around in
there in the interior of the m87 black
hole for i think it's about 35 hours or
something if i remember rightly before
you meet the end of time
so you go to the end of time ultimately
in the black hole so from your
perspective you go in and you end your
days at the end of time which is called
the singularity in the black hole
whereas from the external perspective
you never cross the horizon so you're
saying if you watched it i wouldn't
change but so what goes in my
consciousness my no you would you would
go in
there's a thing called the equivalence
principle in relativity fundamental to
einstein's theory which says that you
wouldn't notice
so you you could fall in across the
horizon of the black hole into the
interior and you would notice nothing
you'd sit there looking at your watch
you would tick at one second per second
you would feel no ill effects at all in
you go but from the external perspective
you never get in
um and uh that so the the modern
understanding
is that both are true
so our universe is constructed in a very
strange way where things that you might
think are a contradiction um actually
it just depends on your point of view
whether you got in or not um but the
outcome
it ultimately is the same so no
contradictions appear and that's been
central to black hole research it's got
a fancy name it's called black hole
complementarity
and it's broadly speaking thought to be
correct
now
but it's really it challenges us to
think about what we mean by reality
because it means that our reality is
so strange that so much stranger than we
could possibly have imagined still work
still works the laws of nature apply
but it's not quite what we expected you
know our common sense is not a good
guide how strange do you think it is how
far can your mind go everybody's mind i
mean that this is the wonderful thing
about um
about science it's not i always when i
go into school sometimes and uh you know
people
have a tendency to think well scientists
are just really clever well you are
clever i mean you are a clover
scientists are not any cleverer than
anybody else right they're just people
that spent their time
learning about stuff like this um
they're no cleverer than someone who's a
great musician
or a football player or whatever it is a
great sports person that it's just it's
all about practice and about the thing
that captures your imagination and i
think you know to be a good guitarist
you have to practice as long as you have
to practice to be a good physicist
pretty much you're just practicing
different things i'm curious about space
and time and
[Music]
density and dimensions and all of that
and
along with that i'm curious about
how general relativity and quantum
mechanics don't
aren't always in sync
so
maybe explaining what quantum mechanics
and general relativity are and where
they don't where they don't jive and
then going into space and time and i'm
just curious maybe
maybe
it maybe it's a local phenomenon at a
certain density or
um at a certain dimensional level
but isn't something that crosses over
into every aspect of the universe so
what comes to mind when i say all these
things yeah no
they're really exactly the right
questions to ask and general relativity
is a it's a 100 year old theory it was
published in 1915 and it's a theory of
gravity which is ultimately it takes
space and time or
woven together into it's often called
the fabric of the universe right it's
called space time but essentially the
picture is that anything matter energy
and warps and distorts the fabric
and the thing that we feel is gravity is
the distortion of the fabric and so
often you see
um people you know imagining it by
rolling a it's kind of a little a ball
around on a on a rubber sheet that's
deformed in some way like a mattress
and and the the ball will be deflected
and that's that's basically what um what
einstein's theory of gravity is and um
quantum mechanics quantum theory
is
um
essentially the old-fashioned way to
think about i suppose it's our theory of
everything else
so it's a theory of particles and forces
how they interact
it's
it's odd it doesn't um
again it's the same age of general
relativity it was around being
formulated around the same time about
100 years ago
and it's um
it doesn't really fit with our intuition
but um that there's there are there are
phenomena like entanglement which is a
really
inherently quantum thing
and a way you can think about that is to
imagine a coin that you can toss right
heads or tails
um
and so
it then imagine two coins and i could
separate them and i could toss one of
them that would be heads and that would
be tails and so on but there's an idea
if you had a quantum coin you can set
these things up these two coins
such that they're in
what's called the states where
it's i'll say what it is it's heads
tails plus tails heads for example
so that says
that if i separate these coins if i take
them and separate them to a light year
or across the universe in principle
and i toss one
and i don't know about the other one so
it'd come up 50 heads and 50 tails just
and i wouldn't know any different
and the same with the one that i took to
the other end of the universe
but actually what you'd find if you
could look at both the results of both
of those coin tosses you would find they
never both come up heads or both come up
tails
ever so that's what's called an
entangled system
um and it's unique to quantum mechanics
it's not
weird in a sense we use it in quantum
computers so it's an everyday
feature of the world but it's not a
feature that we're familiar with so
so quantum mechanics is is is an odd
theory but it's very well understood and
it underpins modern electronics and
lasers and all sorts of things so it
works
um but you're right to say that the the
great clash
that stephen hawking really precipitated
and thinking about black holes
was that
was a clash between a quantum mechanical
description of the black hole and a
purely gravitational description and
then ultimately it's been resolved i
think in in in favor of quantum theory
so there are one or two physicists there
a few physicists wouldn't agree with
that but i think the consensus is
that quantum theory is the base thing
and actually entanglement so that thing
i described about this kind of strange
link between the quantum coins yeah um
entanglement we're now strongly
suspecting builds up space and time
so space and time themselves
are coming from
emerging from quantum entanglement and
so i think um that we're in the early
stages of understanding how that happens
and it's really new research
but that's really where we are so i
think i would be safe to say
and i think most physicists would agree
that the base level of the universe is
quantum
and all this space and time and gravity
stuff
really are coming out of the quantum
theory
so you're saying that the quote the
penny or whatever the coin is has at one
part of the one side of the universe
it's a heads and the other side of the
universe it's a tails and it always
correlates yeah so it's a
polarity is it sort of the
does that even is that even matter is
polarity part of that of like you know
the universe trying to balance itself
no it's it's the fact that the you can
have a description just in our normal
world
we have a a description of these
of things
that are that are completely separate
from each other so the coins would be
you could you could correlate them by
saying i will give you
a little box
which has two coins in and i'll always
set them up so one's heads and ones
tails or something like that the key
thing about entanglement
is that the system is set up
so that you don't know you can know
everything about the system so it is
in quantum language heads tails plus
tails heads that's what it is that's a
complete 100 description of that system
but if i separate out the bits i know
nothing about the two bits of the thing
at all
right they're completely correlated all
the information about the system is
distributed across the whole thing
none of it's in the individual parts
so you look at an individual part it'll
be completely random heads tails 50 of
the time
but the whole thing is set up in such a
way that if you set it up and take these
coins away
uh
if that one's going to be tails this
one's going to be heads they weren't
either
before those measurements were made
before the coins were tossed they
weren't secretly heads so secretly tails
so it's a completely different logic
it's a lot different logical structure
and so it's very counter-intuitive but
it turned out polarity that there's a
property of particles called spin
where this is realized so they're like
quantum coins really
and we use it now in a quantum
cryptography for example so this is
becoming
technology now this this idea of using
entanglement and also in quantum
computing extremely exciting so so we're
now this is not just wishy-washy wild
stuff it's it's fundamental we use it we
use it in laboratories as it's what
people think of entanglement as an
information resource now a resource that
we can use to build computers
um
but it's profound
because it it really does seem to be the
case
that
entanglement builds up space-time
so it's almost like it's the
underpinning structure i mean imagine a
world where the fundamental level space
which is this thing we take for granted
it's the room that we're in we talk
about things being one mile apart or
something we think we know what we mean
by distance and separation
actually no underpinning that it does
seem
is a is a world of quantum entanglements
in which there is no concept of distance
or separation or space
it emerges it's like it's like saying um
you know you i talk about us right we
you right what are you you're a human
being and you're thinking and feeling
and we're having this conversation
but actually there's another level
at which you could call a deeper level
where you're just atoms
so you're just protons and neutrons and
electrons and the protons and neutrons
are made of quarks and they're all stuck
together
and that's a description of you i mean
that's true
it doesn't it's true
but it isn't you it isn't it feels like
it isn't all there is to you right
there's also you
a human being with thoughts and feelings
and you know the
the most wonderful structure in the
universe which is what human beings are
in the same way we're saying that um
that's face and time are like that and
and it's it's as incomprehensible but
then again no less incomprehensible is
that the fact that a human being can be
made of atoms what we're saying is space
and time can be made of
something else
which seems to be quantum entanglement
and that's what einstein said spooky
thing called spooky things happening
happening at a distance right einstein
really didn't like it yeah so he told
that
spooky action at a distance he didn't
think the world behaved like that and
really never
i mean he understood very well quantum
mechanics he said it's a myth that he
didn't
he understood the theory he was one of
the instigators of it so he understood
it perfectly well just didn't like it
right he thought that really it's not
going to be the base description there's
going to be something else
actually
that now in the 21st century we think no
there isn't anything else that's really
it that is direct the way the world
behaves at a deep level
and um the things that we're really
familiar with um actually just emerge
from this deeper level
do you think we're getting closer to a
theory of everything
yeah i really do actually um i mean
you've got to describe what that is i
mean it doesn't mean that we know
everything right but is there an
equation that you could is there an
equation that explains how things happen
at in every way at every level at least
at this point in time
i think i mean i should roll back when i
said yes i'm going to now say
don't know right but what i'm going to
say is that our study of black holes
as is
pushing us and this is really papers and
i talk about these in the live show i
think it's really wonderful because i'm
talking about research that's been done
now so papers have been published in
2021 2022
this work
is revealing a deeper level of
description of reality and whether it's
the base level
um we we have no idea i mean it could be
you carry on what's that saying it's
turtles all the way down right who knows
who knows where the tower of turtles
ends um i don't know anything about
turtles but it could be it could be
that we're certainly getting a glimpse
of a deeper description of reality i
think that's fair to say now whether
that is a theory of everything whether
it's the base level theory i really
don't think anybody knows
and it's almost not worth speculating
because it's kind of meaningless
probably um all we can do is keep
digging and the wonderful thing about
this work that einstein
you know set in motion with general
relativity and quantum mechanics and
then people like stephen hawking and
roger penrose
took that on in the 1970s
and now they're the great physicists um
in the
you know working now young physicist
netangle heart is one and uh
jeff pennington you this this list of
names people in their twenties mainly
who are uncovering a deeper description
that's uh that's a beginning to bring
these ideas together so it's great to
see this progress that's been made it's
very very exciting at the moment and
it's moving so fast it needs to be
talked about i guess especially based on
not understanding and this whole idea of
being connected
through the quantum field but like where
does consciousness fit into all that and
you know i don't know if that's
something that you specifically study or
if that's just something that you think
about and is there
what what it what are your thoughts on
consciousness and how could that play a
role in this
connectedness and when you talk about us
as humans being protons electrons
neutrons and energy like
what makes us think and have feelings
and thoughts and
you know is that consciousness and is
that the thing connected to everything
i i really don't think so and i don't
i think that
um we don't understand
what consciousness is it's called a hard
problem the people who work in this area
neuroscientists call it the hard problem
we're miles away
i mean i interviewed neil degrasse tyson
and he said when there's a lot of books
being written about something you know
we don't get it yeah it's like it's it's
probably the
human brains are the most complex things
we know of anywhere in the universe
they're harder to understand in many
very many ways than the entire than the
universe itself
by understanding the evolution of
galaxies is kind of
compared to understanding human brains
and so
i we just don't know about consciousness
i
uh what i would say
it's a physical property of the universe
it emerges in accord with the laws of
nature and as i've said we know
basic laws of nature i don't think
you're going to need to understand
quantum gravity to understand
consciousness i think we do very well
with them with with biochemistry and and
uh
this structure of the brain i think will
be understood
uh is what we call room temperature
physics and chemistry and biology right
so the stuff that happens um in the
familiar surroundings in which we live i
think that's where an understanding of
consciousness will come from i don't
think you're going to need to go to
quantum gravity to understand
consciousness so i don't think
entanglement and those things they're a
part of the physical structure
of the brain right so when you you could
you can argue if you want to go down to
drill down into deep chemistry you need
to understand quantum mechanics and
where the electrons are in atoms and so
on but i think ultimately consciousness
is going to be something that's
understood by thinking about atoms and
molecules although we are miles away
from understanding it what about
dark energy and dark matter is that just
code for we don't get it because
well
the dark matter so we should say what
they are first so when we look out we've
got loads of evidence that if you look
into the way that galaxies interact with
each other the way they rotate
the way they formed in the early
universe we've got huge amounts of
evidence that there's more matter out
there
than we see shining in the sky or
interstellar gas and dust and so on and
it it's pretty strong evidence
that that's some kind of subatomic
particle that we've not yet discovered
but we see it through its gravitational
influence
and that we have wonderful models of all
sorts of things many different
observations and they all point in that
direction and we to be honest we thought
i think many of us thought that the
large hadron collider is certain
we'd have seen some evidence for these
dark matter particles we'd be making
them in particle collisions and we
haven't done and uh that's a surprise
so we're still looking and that that
machine has been upgraded and we're
looking and so we might do but i think
it's one of those things it's science
nature is a
always perplexing and surprising and
outsmarts us all the time so we haven't
found yet
what that particle might be so it's
still open that there's something else
going on but we're pretty sure
um
dark energy is a different thing it's um
we are again pretty sure that the
universe is accelerating in its
expansion now
and that was a tremendous discovery it
was made in the 1990s
and uh einstein's theory the venerable
theory of general relativity
tells us that if we see how the universe
is expanding and changing and stretching
so the fabric of the universe is
stretching
it allows us to discern what's in it
the kind of stuff how much matter and
dark matter
and we find that we need some other
stuff
called dark energy which is allowed in
the theory so einstein knew about it and
he had one model for it called the
cosmological constant that he put in the
theory and so it's there um we
but we really don't understand at a deep
level what it is uh it's one of the
great mysteries and maybe
you know we're to speculate maybe we're
going to need the the understanding of
space and time that we're getting from
black hole research in order to make
more progress in understanding the
nature of dark energy maybe
so it's it's exciting we're talking
about the frontier but the observation
is
that the universe is expanding and it's
accelerating in its expansion
and that's what dark energy is
so a capsule term for whatever's doing
that
which is a pretty good observation of
the universe that we have so
is there a possibility that there's a
correlation between quantum entanglement
and this because it is assuming that
there's some kind of
energy needed for that there's some kind
of communication of some sort and is
there
and since we don't understand what it is
is it possible that that's part of that
fabric or that yep
absolutely so it's a great question and
yes i think that um
if we're beginning to see
that
and as i said most many physicists not
all would agree with this what i'm going
to say so we're beginning to see that
space
emerges from quantum entanglement
and dark energy the this this
accelerating expansion of the universe
is something to do with space it's some
property of space
so it's not we're a long way off but it
uh but it's it's a reasonable
um kind of guess that
it may be that we need to understand
more about the what the nature's face
itself in order to understand what dark
energy is it doesn't have to be
and there are theories that have it's
some kind of new field that permeates
the universe and so on but it does seem
to be
something to do with space itself or so
there is something fundamental in there
that we don't understand at the moment
yeah yeah are you ever afraid that
us as humans
are just maybe not supposed to get it
like we don't have the capability of
quantifying
understanding
the reality of the universe well we
all we can do is say that we haven't
come up to that barrier yet
and i mean there's a great uh physicist
here a friend of mine martin rhys lord
reese he's a he was the astronomer royal
isn't that a great thing astronomer
royal right and so and he he's made that
point that it it's possible that we're
just not smart enough so when we talk
about a theory of everything it may be
there is one but it's just beyond our
capabilities but we have no evidence
that we've not reached the limit yet and
i think we thought we might we were
confused about
black holes for a long long time
and and i think many scientists even
you know 10 years even five years ago
would think oh well you know this is
this is something to the far future
you know and then suddenly in the last
few years a few really clever people
buildings literally standing on the
shoulders of giants as newton said um
have actually made a breakthrough and
found a way
of making really rapid progress so um so
you know all i can say is that usually
as of now
we've been smart enough which is a
remarkable thing i always wonder for
just zeros and ones are we a stimulation
well there's two
those don't follow from each other so
are we just zeros and ones john wheeler
one of my great heroes one of the great
physicists the greatest of the 20th
century um had this idea he talked about
it from bit
so he used to say the information theory
right the theory the computing theory
ones and zeros or q bits which are the
quantum versions of that would underlie
reality
in some way and that's uh in
the message that the black hole physics
is giving to us it's we've got to this
realization through thinking about
information
information conservation
how information is shared in systems how
it comes out of systems um like black
holes and hawking radiation and so on so
there is some um
a good case to be made that thinking in
terms of bits of information theory
is it allows us a very much more
powerful window onto nature
and so whether that is telling you
that the universe is is made of bits at
a fundamental level um maybe
um but i don't think you can extrapolate
from that to say that we live in a
simulation
it might just be
that the base level of reality is
best understood and described in terms
of
bits of information um i i think it's a
huge leap
for which we have no evidence at all to
say therefore we live in a great big
quantum computer
i think that's going
the correct thing to say is it's
interesting
that many of the ideas from quantum
computing
are turning out to be useful in
describing physical reality that's
clearly true right um but
but to go the extra mile and say
therefore we live inside a big computer
seems to me to be a grotesque
over extension the reality of that would
be sad
but it kind of doesn't even change
anything
the truth of the reality and it helps
you maybe understand what's possible or
what's not possible but i find it
fascinating how people can fall into
patterns and archetypes and there are
certain disorders or cancers or anything
and they have they have a pattern
there can be two people that have no
idea what they have going on but they
develop the same pattern of something
whether it's a personality disorder or a
disease and i just find that kind of
fascinating yeah um
patterns i mean that's what we do that's
what we search for in nature that's how
you do science really you're looking for
patterns and they're that you know
there's a wonderful book
um by uh johannes kepler so kepler was
around in the 1620s right so before
kepler kepler
and he wrote a book called the six
cornered snowflake which is one of my
favorite books it's brilliant book okay
and he's talking about walking across a
bridge in prague
and a snowflake lands on his arm and he
looks at it and he he starts thinking
about this thing the the snowflakes
they're all the same but they're all
different
so what is it telling us and in 1620
kepler
starts thinking well it must be telling
us about the underlying structure
there's something in there
that it's it's something deeply hidden
and of course he's right it's the water
molecule that's doing it but he could
not know that he didn't know about atoms
or molecules but it's wonderful
and at the end he says this is wonderful
the translation of it i have says that
i'm knocking on the doors of chemistry
it says but i must leave it i must leave
this to you dear reader right to the
future because i can't go any further i
don't know enough
but it knocking on the doors of
chemistry and i love that book it's so
wonderful it's such a beautiful uh
what when you kepler
was a genius there's no doubt when you
read that book he's funny and he's
insightful and he was a modern mind at
the level of the best physicist that we
have working today but in this world
where he didn't know very much but he's
still asking the right questions he's
saying does the pattern the pattern in
the snowflake what is it
the six six sixty kind of six corner
pattern thing what is it telling me
about the deep structure of nature and
it's wonderful it makes me think of
cymatics and thinking about how
you know you've seen the sand on the
drum and they can play it and it short
shapes different patterns and how this
pattern can repeat in nature and how
you know this again this pattern emerges
in different forms at different levels
in different ways whether it's an animal
or
music and
you wonder what that significance is
yeah
and absolutely and it's about asking
that question it's about what the the
regularities i see in nature the shape
of the snowflake the swirls of the
galaxies
the you know the the way that black
holes behave um what are those patterns
telling me about the underlying
structure and that that's what science
is what is your
what is the most important or most
critical question that you hope
can be answered
in your lifetime i would love to know um
whether we're alone in this neighborhood
so i'd love to know whether there's life
on mars
um whether there's life in our solar
system whether there's life nearby i'll
never know you know you never know if
the answer is negative we'll never know
um because we can't survey the entire
universe but it would be lovely to see
that there are other microbes and we're
searching for that on mars now so so
it's not beyond the realms of
possibility
and the other one is the the uh to see
how the black hole research develops
because ultimately um that that that's
our window onto the origin of the
universe if indeed the universe had an
origin
so we don't have the theoretical tools
yet to talk about
really
um
what happened you know did the universe
have an origin in time or not we were
really
in the dark we don't really know
and we know there's a big bang but we
don't know if there's things before that
or what the universe was like before
that so i think
that that's what we need that's where we
need what you revert to the theory of
everything quantum gravity and those
theories are
closer i think than everybody thought
five years ago well i'll ask you the
same question i asked neil i'm like do
you think that we're maybe looking for
the wrong thing
you know like we're looking for us
but we fit perfectly into this
environment which is so fragile as you
said well um
it's possible i mean that's one of the
reasons we're bringing the samples back
from mars actually because um
it's so difficult
to know what to look for when you're
looking for living things but when
you're looking for civilizations
possibly again i mean people make the
argument that maybe there are there are
uh machines from other civilizations
around and maybe they're too small maybe
you know if if they were really smart
and their space probes were the size of
iphones would we notice right the answer
is probably no no baths exactly so
so you're right we we we you know all we
can say is that in in the limited
time we've had and we've looked and
we've seen no evidence of anything but
you're right i mean it could just be
because things are really small
and we just don't see them
right or it's in the dark energy and
it's in a different dimension and it's
information as opposed to
matter like this or what we call matter
argument that um we
we're b we have a pretty deep
understanding of the universe and if you
look if you want to look for different
forms of matter different forces of
nature
um
you know
it has to be quite subtle um because
we're pretty good at exploring the
universe in some detail but you know the
science as i said is about understanding
that you don't know everything
so we certainly don't know everything
such a humble place to come from you're
starting your tour uh of the us and
canada right how many stops are you
making oh it's about 50 or something
like that it's a huge tour so we started
are you coming to arizona i'm not coming
to arizona sadly yet
so no
i'm so surprised we're not because
tucson is one of my favorite cities and
i'm i'm i was quite disappointed that at
the moment we don't have a show there
but um we've got shows across you know
all down into texas and all across the
northeast and then all down the west
coast uh midwest
so
and canada as well so we start on um i
don't know when the podcast goes we
start on friday so that would be what
would that be the 20
what is it 20 something
i don't even know see i'm a physicist so
i don't know what what
you're a numbers guy come on
yeah 22nd 22nd in 22nd in washington
and dc and then on from there and we're
it's about three months in total we
don't finish until july
you're a rock star
well you know um
i think the era of stadium cosmology is
upon us i love it i i i very much love
it and if you
are coming anywhere within the arizona
region i would love to come and see
your pres your lecture and your
all of your examples on the screen i'm
sure you have that didn't you have a
huge show that had like giant screens at
some point we're bringing them to the
u.s so we we it's all led screens in the
uk
where we have 15 000 people come to the
shows so we have these huge screens or a
hundred feet wide
um and uh we just put as much as it as
we can into every theater so um so
we'll be in um where are we near you
we're in in into texas and then places
like that
denver salt lake city we will put um as
much screen as we can in there and the
graphics have been developed you know
for arenas and so therefore
in a theater you get a different
experience and you get an experience you
couldn't have had in
it you know no one could afford to do
that in theaters
but because we also have the arenas in
the uk and australia and some big shows
in canada
then we can spend the money on the
graphics we use the graphics code from
interstellar for example to simulate
black holes we've used
the unreal engine which is the video
game engine to build virtual worlds
actually rendered in real time in the in
the theater so we can have sunsets and
the lighting rig interacts with the
screen all these things this really
wonderful technology that we can use and
we're bringing it all to the us
and but you get to see it in a more
intimate setting
i would love that and then at some point
you can use like the holographic
principles of some sort and create like
the sky above us in an arena right you
could do it at a stadiums and
yeah just put your put your maps in the
sky
yeah it's a plan and we've got a
classical music version because there's
some there's some classical music in the
show so we're gonna in 2023 we're going
to bring the show out and hopefully to
the us and canada with orchestras and do
the same thing
in a slightly different show with a
symphony orchestra so we've got we've
got big plans you're going to create a
little vortex when you do that
you love it
i don't even know what that means but it
sounds cool i'll take it yeah
all right well thank you so much brian
this is fascinating and i could talk
your ear off but i gotta go they said i
gotta go good luck on the tour and i
hope i see you along the way well and so
we'll find out i'll find out where the
nearest show is and you you must come
i'd love to see you so um
that's um
i will send you a message of where the
nearest one is and send a car
send a car i'll send a coffee
i'll drive it you send the car and i'll
drive it okay
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button